[Musique]
rouler à un projet porté par l'agression
au coude on a dit beaucoup dans
l'échangé que tata séance encore une
autre changement et on voulait aussi un
projet porté comporter avec des agents
bien réservé aux dépens du lightning
des principes qui ont été choisis à
l'unanimité par deux et sans de l'époque
fondation de la pure colette ici même à
sélestat le 26 novembre dernier
correspond vraiment à la bnrm
département et des départements c'est la
proximité est vrai qu'elle est vraiment
je vous renvoie à tirer parti de
l'expérience pardo que vous allez me
séparément dans la nuit et les quatre
ans et demi
nous allons devoir nous montrer à la
hauteur de la confiance
[Musique]
paris
en tout ils ont accepté que soit mise en
oeuvre de ce projet alors au site est
très forte attente de nos concitoyens
les alsaciens 4 83% à souhait de la
création du collectif parce que cette
démarche menée par auto de collectivités
le vis pas seulement à vos luminaires
deux collectivités voisines et amies
mais n'en a pas projets de toutes parts
la chair et le sang ne sort d'une belle
famille une famille crise appelle
l'alsace